The lack of deaths in the brewery is perhaps a less salient part of
John Snow's map, but it's certainly an interesting one.
As it turns out, the brewery gave an unlimited beer allowance to its workers,
and since the fermentation process killed the cholera bacteria,
none of the workers contracted the disease.
You can read more about the outbreak and
John Snow's discovery in the instructor notes.
His work in visualization with a start of modern epidemiology.
John Snow demonstrated how data visualization can be
used to trace the spread of disease.
In this case, a single pump carrying contaminated water throughout a community.
Here's a different interactive visualization that comes from The Guardian,
which encodes missing values in a slightly different way.
This visualization dis, displays the extent to which gay rights are protected by
law in each of the states as of May 2012.
States that have no laws or
that are unclear about the laws have this light grey coloring.
And states that prohibit or ban gay rights have the striped pattern.
For example, many states in the northeast have employment laws which
prohibit discrimination based on sexual orientation and gender.
While most states in the southeast and
many in the midwest lack such employment laws.
This is an interesting visualization because it makes use of texture or
pattern to represent different aspects about the states.
For example, this outer red ring displays many states that prohibit or
ban same sex marriage.
And this darker blue inner ring shows a few states that do
not permit adoption by a single person or joint adoption by same sex couples.
Between this visualization and John Snow's map we can see that
there are many ways to encode values of zero, missing values, or
perhaps other categorical values of data like in this visualization.
So now I'd like to turn it over to you.